this afternoon some Henderson parents
are pulling their kids out of school
they're concerned about an overnight
shooting at Corral Academy's Cadence
campus Henderson Police say someone shot
out several Windows overnight eight news
now education reporter Joshua peguero
live from the campus near Warm Springs
and Boulder Highway Joshua
John I want to show you within the last
few minutes several law enforcement
agencies have arrived at the scene right
here you're looking at the Henderson
Fire Department where they're placing
markings marking some of the bullet
holes that were left overnight there's
also a yellow crime scene tape that was
just placed within the last 15 minutes
and as you mentioned parents are upset
with coral Academy administrators for
not canceling classes today and then
Supreme say they originally arrived at 3
40 this morning for reports of an
unknown person shooting a building
window there were no injuries the school
sending email to parents at the campus
was shot in random places shattering
three Windows they had the shooting
wasn't directed at any person but that
wasn't enough to put parents and
students at ease
that's the library up there that could
have easily been a kid shot
and then what you know why can't we take
it serious do the investigation find out
what happened do we have a suspect that
we have them in custody and then maybe
send the kids to school
now Coral Academy says armed staff
Personnel were present at campus today
and also part of the some of the law
enforcement agencies that arrive were
ATF you're looking at several of the
other law enforcement agencies that
arrived on scene looks like they're
looking for some evidence around the
campus uh curl Academy is on a soft
lockdown meaning that no visitors were
allowed to enter the building today
reporting live near warm spring roads
and Boulder Highway Joshua baguero eight
news now all right Joshua thank you very
much and as you can see on the screen
there Henderson police are monitoring
choral Academy there to the Cadence
campus and they're in fact at the scene
right now